في المقابل قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يائير لابيد ان استعاده المخطوفين
ستم ستتم من خلال ما وصفه بصفقه سيئه
وفضيعه لكن اسرائيل مجبر عليها حسب قوله
اضاف الابيد ان الاولويه هي الاستعاده
المخطوفين الذين قال ان اسرائيل تخلت عنهم
كما اعتبر زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه ان
كلا من الوزيرين جانس وايزن كوت يتخبط في
مساله الانسحاب من حكومه الطوارئ
وقال لبيد ان المنظومه السياسيه الحاليه
في اسرائيل هي المشكله وليست الحل وفي
كلمه امام الكنيست قال الابيد انه لم يرى
اسرائيل حزينه مثل اليوم مشيرا الى فقدان
مزيد من الجنود وتضاءل الامل في عوده
الاسرى المنظومه السياسيه اليوم في وضعها
الحالي هي المشكله وليست الحل علينا ان
نسال انفسنا كيف وصلنا الى هذا الوضع من
عشت في هذه الدوله لم تكن حزينه مثل اليوم
الناس مكسورون وممزق القلوب على العائلات
على المختطفين على الجنود الذين يقتلون
كيف وصلنا الى هذا الحال دوله عظمى في
الشرق الاوسط محاطه بتنظيم ارهابي يخترق
الحدود بسيارات دفع رباعي ويقتل مواطنيها
وابنائها مئات الالاف يجلون من بيوتهم ولا
نعلم متى سيعودون
136 مختطفا لدى حماس ولا احد يعلم متى
سيعودون الى اين نحن
ذاهبون